et maintenant l'association
internationale du transport aérien
prévoit qu'il faudra attendre jusqu'en
avant que le trafic aérien ne retrouve
son niveau d'avant la pandémie c'est un
an plus tard que ce qui avait été prévu
en avril
les voyages plus courts à l'intérieur
des pays devrait reprendre plus
rapidement que les vols internationaux
et les compagnies aériennes devraient
perdre plus de 400 milliards de dollars
américains de revenus cette année et
c'est l'entente et laisser l'ensemble de
l'industrie touristique internationale
qui s'est effondré avec cette pandémie
l'organisation mondiale du tourisme nous
apprend qu'en mai le nombre de touristes
internationaux a chuté de 98 % par
rapport à l'an dernier et depuis le
début de l'année le nombre de touristes
internationaux a chuté de 300 millions
entraînant des pertes de 320 milliards
de dollars pour l'industrie c'est perte
représente plus du triple de celle
enregistrée lors de la crise économique
de 2009
et pour parler des conséquences à long
terme de ce recul marqué de l'activité
et aux vestiges en table avec michel
archambault qui est professeur émérite
en tourisme à l'uqam et fondateur de
l'achat de tourisme transat bonjour
monsieur archambault un bonjour monsieur
bourque
on s'attendait à un recul historique
mais l'on comprend mieux l'ampleur alors
les pertes sont trois fois plus
importantes que la crise 2008 2009 c'est
énorme
effectivement c'est une crise profonde
qui marque la fin de la croissance de
l'industrie du tourisme qui est depuis
les dix dernières années que c'est à
dire depuis 2009 avec un taux de
croissance annuelle d'environ 2 4 à 5%
par année et cette année effectivement
avec les chiffres que vous avez donné on
illustre très bien que par exemple au
niveau des emplois plus d'un emploi sur
trois dans l'industrie mondiale vont
être perdus au niveau du tourisme
et ça c'est quand même assez dramatique
pour les employés et au niveau du
chiffre d'affaires vous avez souligné
par exemple au niveau des compagnies
aériennes où on estime les pertes à
quelque 400 à 500 milliards de dollars à
la fin de 2020 et avec une
perte de plus de 3 milliards de
passagers sur une base annuelle
d'environ 4,5 5 milliards de 'passagers
donc on perd plus de 65 % des passagers
au niveau aérien et sa frappe également
l'industrie des croisières comment il
savait l'industrie de l'hébergement que
ce soit mode collaboratif de type airbnb
homeaway mais l'industrie traditionnelle
également donc c'est une crise profonde
qui a rien à voir avec les crises
antérieures que ce soit le strass en
2002 2003 j'ai confiance hier de
nouvelles crises finances de 2008 2009
oui on vous parlait de sa chambre ou
d'un emploi sur trois qui pourraient
être éliminés est ce que le canada puis
québec fera partie de cela où il ya
d'autres pays qui pourraient être
touchés davantage c'est la
caractéristique de cette pandémie c'est
que les mondiale et elle touche
l'ensemble des continents
il ya personne actuellement à ce que je
sache qui n'est pas soumis aux effets
économiques et sociaux de cette pandémie
et contrairement à d'autres crises
majeures celle là elle atteint la
planète entière
il ya des pays qui par contre sont plus
fragiles qui dépendent davantage du
tourisme je pense tout de suite parce
que j'ai fait une recherche aujourd'hui
la thaïlande par exemple france environ
20% de son pib
donc des revenus qui viennent du
tourisme le mexique d'autres pays
également le soutien de cuba ou le maroc
il ya des marchés qui seront fortement
touche également l'espagne celle ci ses
marchés et ses marchés ces marchés sont
surtout sont surtout le fait de tourisme
qui proviennent de l'international
d'étrangers le tourisme domestique
contre - davantage dans d'autres pays
par exemple l'espagne plus de 5
près de 50 % due à des dépenses trixie
touristiques sont défaits de visiteurs
de l'extérieur de l'espagne et il en est
de même pour la thaïlande et d'autres
pays que ce soit évidemment les caraïbes
quelques pays et dans les caraïbes donc
et même en amérique latine qui
actuellement
ou ans par est le continent le plus
touché par la pandémie
alors c'est évident que au niveau du
tourisme
c'est une industrie qui durement
durement l'une des plus durement farhat
et lorsqu'on combine l'ensemble des
secteurs qui constituent cette industrie
est ce qu'on va ressentir ses effets à
long terme où on peut espérer que dans 2
3 ans à reviennent tranquillement
produite à la normale on parle de 2023
2024 et je pense que effectivement entre
temps là la seule croissance qui
pourrait peut-être qu'on peut qu'on peut
voir à l'heure actuelle c'est là elle
est due aux domestiques c'est-à-dire au
tourisme qui visitent leur propre pays
ou nombreuses provinces où la propre
région donc la croissance il ya un début
de croissance
elle provient du tourisme domestique
dits domestiques et évidemment ça va
s'accompagner avec une prise de
conscience écologique
une transition écologique qui va faire
en sorte que effectivement si on assista
- tourisme ya moins de déchets mais il
ya moins de retombées économiques
étant donné que des retombées
économiques de touristes étrangers
laisse plus beaucoup plus perdre
capitaux que le tourisme domestique en
général ils le tourisme local parce que
vous venez tout juste d'en parler alors
c'est une tendance forte la tout le
moins lors des deux trois prochaines
années
effectivement donc le tourisme local
faut être c'est certain et il s'agit de
récupérer des par exemple le prouve le
québec ou le canada
les milliards que sont dépensés par les
canadiens à l'extérieur du canada et du
québec en trop essayer d'intéresser ces
gens là à visiter leur propre pays mais
évidemment quand on pense par exemple à
l'exode des snowbirds en hiver est-ce
que la floride ou l'arizona où la base
que la californie au mexique mans vont
être ouverts on ne sait pas un des
grandes inconnues de cette pandémie ce
qu'on ne sait pas quand on va pouvoir
rpt voyager dans la normalité et man
your man on man
oui effectivement donc et ça que vont
faire ces personnes qui voyageaient
normalement pendant la période hivernale
pour tuer univers et non pas pour fuir
le coville lors ces gens là on y va
falloir que les provinces les pays leur
propose des solutions et les solutions
souvent induits par la crise
actuellement l heure elle est
profondément des grandes villes
ce sont des grandes villes au niveau et
le tourisme urbain et durement plus
frappés que le tourisme dans les leurs à
10 ans dans les régions en villégiature
et on recherche beaucoup le tourisme
vert entre guillemets me revient en tête
en 30 secondes parce que vous avez parlé
des régions et qui sont bénéficiaires
les régions devront s'adapter également
on a vu ce qui s'est passé également
aussi en gaspésie ont nulle les effets
néfastes également aussi du tourisme
vous en espérant que ce n'est qu'un
épisode et que cet épisode le de choc ne
se répétera pas parce que c'est aller à
l'encontre de toutes les pratiques éco
touristique
quand on voit des images comme on a vu
récemment et ça va aller en compte de ce
qu'on pense que nouveau tourisme va
impliquer en termes de valeur auprès des
voyageurs et je pense que le tourisme
durable doit se voit s'imposer comme
étant au car la construction de cette
industrie là prétend qu'un second est ce
qu'on se dirige vers un assainissement
du touriste parce que vous savez il ya
des marchés qui était complètement
saturée la barcelone venise dubrovnik
alors est ce qu'on peut espérer ça je
pense que effectivement vaut miser
davantage sur la qualité que sur la
quantité
on va sans doute prendre des pratiques
de contingentement de mieux gérer des
flux touristiques sont trois autres
saisons et on va on va c'est aussi un
appel à attendait des pratiques pour
contrer les changements climatiques qui
ont amené par également sur le plan
touristique dont on espère qu'ils vont
avoir qu'on va assister à des effets
relativement positif de cette crise là
malgré que le fait que le peuple
ensemble pas simplement des industries
mais des indices
un tracteur on peut l'espérer michel ars
michel archambault merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous obséder mathieu
mault au revoir